jirô 70,000 precious American lives were
taken because of the poison the cartels
bring into our country under my
administration drug overdose death spell
for the first time in nearly 30 years
and they fell fairly substantially
unfortunately the shutdown's caused by
the China virus have led to a recent
rise in overdose deaths still below the
level that they were at but nevertheless
they went up a little bit this is one of
the reasons that we're working to safely
and responsibly reopen our country
reopen our schools get our country going
again a hundred percent we're setting
records on jobs we're setting records on
many different things we're going to
have a great third quarter third quarter
is going to be tremendous numbers fourth
quarter likewise and next year
economically will be one of the best
years we've ever had but you'll see the
numbers starting to come out really
really high in the third quarter and
you've already seen the record-breaking
job numbers Nasdaq just hit recently
about 12 record highs 12 days record
highs and the other markets are right
behind it they'll be hitting records
hopefully very shortly also that means
people have a lot of confidence in what
we're doing with the help of the heroes
here at South come coast guard CBP DEA
and law enforcement will work
relentlessly to seize illegal drugs
arrests while traffickers the
traffickers are truly vile they're
terrible terrible people what they do
mostly to women and children but women
and dismantle criminal cartels who are
responsible for the deaths of thousands
and thousands of Americans I'd like now
to introduce secretary aspir to say a
few words more please yes thank you very
much thank you very much thank you Mark
and good afternoon everyone
it's a pleasure to be here today to
discuss the successes of our enhanced
counter of narcotics operations in the
eastern Pacific Ocean and the Caribbean
Sea the department defense began this
initiative alongside our internet
interagency partners at the president's
direction on April 1st as part of our
whole of government effort to combat the
flow of illicit drugs into our country
and to protect the American
people transnational criminal
organizations have destroyed far too
many American lives by smuggling heroin
cocaine fentanyl and methamphetamines
from our country leading to drug
overdoses and addiction in our
communities
moreover the profits derived from these
activities support a range of bad actors
from cartels in Mexico to the
illegitimate Maduro regime which
continues to oppress the Venezuelan
people despite the challenges posed by
the corona virus pandemic are enhanced
counter narcotics operations have shown
great success in countering those
threats by disrupting the flow of
illicit drugs denying our adversaries
financial resources and strengthening
the capacity of partner countries in the
region since the end of March we have
employed in the u.s. Southern Command
area of responsibility
seventy-five percent more surveillance
aircraft and 65% more ships than normal
for drug interdiction these additional
assets include four Navy destroyers five
Coast Guard cutters and eight aircraft
currently nearly a dozen Navy and Coast
Guard ships and over 15 aircraft from
across the interagency are supporting
our efforts in addition to security
forces deployed to the region further we
have successfully engaged and encouraged
22 partner nations to join us in this
fight and step up their involvement in
drug interdictions as a result of these
enhanced operations SOUTHCOM and our
interagency and international partners
have disrupted more than 122 metric tons
of cocaine as well as over 18,000 pounds
of marijuana we did not nearly two
billion dollars in drug profits
increased our targeting of known
smuggling maritime events by sixty
percent and neutralized dozens of
members of transnational criminal
organizations these efforts have been
critical to saving countless American
lives and making our communities
healthier healthier safer and stronger I
want to thank the president president
Trump for his leadership and bringing us
together and support this critical
mission thank you sir and I'm grateful
for the hard work of our partners
including the US Coast Guard the
Department of Homeland Security the Drug
Enforcement Administration the
Department of Justice members of the
intelligence community and support from
Congress as well for all there
efforts together we will maintain our
enhanced presence in the region keep the
pressure on transnational criminal
groups and protect America and our
communities from the scourge of illicit
drugs thank you thank you sir
mr. president secretary osburgh
secretary wolf shipmate Carl Schultz
hometown congressman here Mario Diaz
Blart thank you all for your support on
this important mission its mission is
vital to our homeland defense it truly
is and I'm proud to say the efforts are
making a difference mr. president and
they're saving lives and a team here
that's assembled deserves the credit but
the resources that you've ordered have
have made that happen other nations have
stepped up mr. president Colombia for
one have stepped up it despite kovat US
leadership has been a key key piece
Emmis mr. president I would just want to
show a map I have a little version front
of you just orient on the on the
hemisphere here if we could put the map
up so South comes responsibility of this
western hemisphere really it's our
neighborhood it's it's so close to home
so what impacts the neighbors really has
a high impact on us at home mr.
president and that's why this is so
important there's so much opportunity
here it's our number two trading partner
outside of Asia and so trade economics
and democracy importantly and partner
nations are willing they want to work
with us and we work with partners so
from Guatemala on south and out into the
Caribbean but that's under assault as
vicious circle of threats that you see
led by the transnational criminal
organizations about a 90 billion dollar
a year enterprise and and it's feeds off
corruption and now the added instability
of kovat but I as I said that partners
have stepped up despite the kovat which
is a tribute to their to their security
teams
there's also another aspect in this
neighborhood of ours in its you know
what we call a national defense strategy
great power competition so China has
certainly looked at this neighborhood is
an opportunity for them and when you
think about the proximity of some of
their investments Jamaica and El
Salvador it's just as close to watching
in as as is to Miami is if you look at
comparative distances the slide please
but what our citizens want I know
certainly my dad in Western PA who's
watching once is they want to know if
we're making a difference and the
numbers as we've stated really have at
15% nor disruptions that's detainees
that strug's off the street that said
122 metric tons mr. president and 60%
more targeting is a big deal for us
because that means we can put more
assets on more targets and the enemies
seen that we've gotten information from
our intelligence agencies that says the
enemy's watch that and they're waiting
and they're stockpiling and they're
trying to change their tactics those
additional Navy ships the AWACS from the
air force Oklahoma guard mc12 DEA agents
the whole team effort really as they
make a difference here but that 70%
partner participation is key mr.
president and I think of it this way of
you know on the field to compete when
you go to golf or baseball you want the
best players with you and we certainly
have those winners with us here today
just wanted to introduce you to to mr.
president Berger general Juan Carlos
Correa if you'd stand up general
president president Duque had sent us
his best and paying for it so he comes
here fully paid by Columbia and he works
for me that's a recognition that
Columbia is with us in world in the
Korean War and there with us today and
making a difference and our Brazilian
President bowls narrow a very new
addition to our headquarters Major
General daveed one of the sharpest and
Brazilian armed forces is in our j5
organization again Brazilian paying for
him to come here and work for me to make
a difference as security you know
Brazil's been with us since World War
two and our relationship is growing even
stronger mr. president and last two
points mr. president that tactical into
this fight and you remember being in Key
West at joint interagency task force
South - I thought you rang that Bell
right and the war fighters responsible
for that fight
Rear Admiral Doug fierce at the end
commands GI self and master chief Henry
Ledet is the senior enlisted there
they're the ones that are really day in
and day out the tactical edge of this
fight sir and I'll tell you what's mr.
president they're ringing the enemy's
Bell every day sir who seem to be that's
a fantastic job thank you very much mr.
congressman like to say something
Thank You mr. president nothing nothing
prepared but but I can't tell you in my
time of Congress which is now eight
almost 18 years this region has frankly
been I just barely any attention paid to
it and sometimes when the attention was
paid bad things or done I will tell you
that your administration has emphasized
freedom I want to thank you by the way
on a personal note a little bit of a
more parochial no for your emphasis on
helping the people of Venezuela regain
their freedom helping the people of
Nicaragua regain their freedom
you
changes to makes it a lot easier for you
Robert please
mr. president thank you I want to take
folks back to April 1st as the Cova
crisis was breaking and all attention
was focused on it the president had the
foresight to launch an enhanced
operations has dropped the flow of
dangerous drugs the United States from
narco-terrorists our adversaries
believed that the United States would be
distracted but mr. president you weren't
distracted and I think he remember you
sent secretary wolf and Admiral shawl
secretary asked for Attorney General
guar me out to make the announcement on
this operation the traffickers use their
funds for nefarious purposes among them
to finance the regime of Nicolas Maduro
the illegitimate regime in Venezuela and
four years venezuela has flooded the
United States with cocaine it poisons
our communities and it feels dangerous
epidemic of addiction that threatens the
safety and security of all Americans the
situation in Venezuela has gotten so bad
that earlier this week admiral fuller
fowler called the venezuela a paradise
for drug traffickers who enjoy the
support and cooperation of the Maduro
regime and his allies at a crackdown on
the the traffickers president Trump
deployed additional ships aircraft
security forces that you've heard about
but the other thing that he did which is
is less focused on is he rallied our 22
nation coalition partnership to help in
this effort to interdict drugs so that
fight includes as you've heard Colombia
Ecuador Honduras El Salvador on the
flight down from Air Force One mr.
president I told you I was on the phone
with my counterpart in the Netherlands
the Dutch national security adviser
they've been part of this coalition
fight and they're they're very proud to
be partnered up with Customs and Border
Patrol DEA the Coast Guard our military
working in the Caribbean in the eastern
Pacific or they've had where we've all
had a huge effect in addition to this
operation the Colombian led operation
Orion five and partnership with the
United States has disrupted or seized
approximately 50 additional metric tons
of cocaine that would have otherwise
come into our country mr. president so
president Trump has been resolute in his
commitment to protecting the American
people from the scourge of narco
terrorists and traffickers
our military deployments the Caribbean
and in the eastern Pacific will endure
those profiting from illicit drugs and
the destruction of our communities will
be brought to justice the United States
will continue its maximum pressure
campaign the Maduro regime which has a
criminal hold over venezuela and i can
tell for that for the Venezuelan people
when I speak with President Trump he
asked almost every day how are things
going in venezuela of what can we do to
help the Venezuelan people
this operation is part of that effort
Venezuela is a narco State led by a
criminal illegitimate regime and the
people of Venezuela are suffering
because of Maduro mr. president you've
been committed to cutting off his
financial lifelines identifying ways to
continue to support the Venezuelan
people and ensure the unfettered flow of
humanitarian aid to those same people
that are suffering so for those of you
in Venezuela like and I can let you know
the president Trump continues to stand
with you he stands with interim
president quite oath the democratically
elected National Assembly and all the
people that are fighting for their
freedom and their basic human rights and
a restoration of democracy and the rule
of law in Venezuela president Trump's
fight against drugs and narco
trafficking in the Caribbean and in the
eastern Pacific are good for the United
States of America they're good for the
people of the region including Venezuela
but they're also good for the entire
world so mr. president it's an honor to
serve with you in this in this effort
thank you for all that you're doing sir
thank you very much Robert and James
please I'm president Trump your
principal drug adviser thank you for
your commitment and your leadership on
the drug issue I echo your thanks to the
men and women who wear a uniform whether
it's the military or whether it's our
state and local law enforcement partners
who are stopping these deadly drugs from
entering our country and thus saving
American lives you laid out a
comprehensive strategy to prevent drug
use before it starts to get more people
into treatment and importantly as we're
talking about today to stop these drugs
from coming into our homeland at your
direction we've implemented a whole
government approach we've made record
investments and we're taking real action
which meant you have received and more
importantly the American people have
received real progress we must recognize
these drug
cells are trying to take advantage of
the pandemic and you are not letting
that happen you were making certain that
those people who are suffering and risk
death are making sure that we are taking
the steps necessary to protect them
that's why your leadership in this step
is so important you're sending a clear
message that this administration that
this country will not let up in our
fight against drug traffickers you're
doing it also with our international
partners for the first time Colombia I
recognize the work done there they
eradicated 13,000 hectares of cocaine in
one month last month in June and that is
before they begin the aerial eradication
that we have talked about so often we
cannot let these drug traffickers take
advantage especially these cocaine
traffickers that are coming up through
this AOR the surge operations are
effective and they're going to continue
and we are going to take the fight to
these drug traffickers you have
relentlessly committed to the American
people by making investments of thirty
six billion dollars for both the
military fight our law enforcement fight
as well as treatment and of course one
of the signature programs of the first
lady something that's really been led by
Kellyanne Conway of speaking to the
American people about the dangers of
drug use the media campaigns that she
and the first lady have done have really
made a huge difference in what has
happened and so I'm very appreciative to
be a colleague of hers we rely on out in
the faller
I'm Mel Schultz Admiral fears and Master
Chief all that as the ones who are out
there actually taking the risks taking
the dangers for the American people we
appreciate what you all are doing and
reared you to continue to be relaxed
thank you thank you very much and Henry
we'd like to say something go ahead I'm
probably serving it up south and I'll
tell you
now you said sir to make sure that we
are building our Newton system do on
this Koba crisis they're doing a degree
sacrifice to their families at times but
they do it want to stop these
transnational so yeah what can go in
your immune system that's an interesting
[Music]
stay in shape that's good I'm gonna have
to start doing that anything that's a
good idea
that's great well thank you and Mario
obviously had a good immune system
because you recovered wasn't pleasant
but you you got there right I don't
recommend that it's a dietary no it's
not good but you did a good job and by
the way thank you for your kind multiple
calls while I was absolutely we've been
a my friend thank you very much
please operation I've been this mission
space for over thirty years I've never
seen this many resources applied to the
problem set of transnational criminal
organizations and counter narcotics
operations so we have under our roof
21 different countries represented by
their foreign liaison officers they work
they come to work every day trying to
lean into this problem set we've got a
whole-of-government from the US
government with a completely joint force
from all the branches of the service as
well as all of our interagency partners
from all the departments and agencies
and beyond what's represented in this
room and so we're just grateful for the
opportunity to lean into the problem and
I can tell you with surety that that
we're targeting and we're getting after
this every single day so thank you for
your time sir well thank you very much I
appreciated that listen we have the best
equipment that we've ever had as a
military we've spent two and a half
trillion dollars on our military
some of its arriving some of it's coming
in but much of its here so when you say
the quality of equipment we definitely
have the best equipment we've ever had
we've the best equipment anyone has as a
military we have things under
construction that we're going to take a
look at one day soon where we have
missiles that go I hear 17 times faster
than any other missile and the normal
type at least and something that nobody
has anywhere in the world 17 times
faster so it's a little hard to spot it
when it goes that fast because by the
time you spot it it's gone but we have
things happening that nobody has even
thought about so thank you very much
you've done a fantastic job you've all
done a really fantastic job and it's an
honor to be here I want to thank all of
the folks behind me - I don't you're
more important than all of us right
[Music]
thank you very much okay thank you that
yours mr. president thank you for the
time and the attention and the resources
and we're going to stay at this mission
it's it's a it's a 24/7 and we are gonna
take the fight to the enemy
leadership here is committed to American
people we are the future and thank you
we've done a great job thank you very
much thank you Admiral
thank you
[Applause]